we learned this morning that an
additional 6.6 million people have lost
jobs and filed for unemployment benefits
now the real numbers are actually much
worse than the official numbers and I'll
explain why in a moment
you might remember that two weeks ago we
learned that in the prior week 3.3
million people lost their jobs last week
we learned that the week before 6.8
million people filed for unemployment
and today we learned that last week 6.6
million more people filed for
unemployment benefits that now gets us
to sixteen point seven million people
losing their jobs and filing for
unemployment benefits in just three
weeks now to understand the magnitude of
this the labor force was right around a
hundred and fifty eight million before
this started that means ten percent of
the labor force has filed for
unemployment benefits in the last three
weeks now the question is can we trust
that number well we can trust it but the
real number is much higher why well
number one there are tons of people who
lost a job but don't qualify for
unemployment benefits not every type of
job necessarily qualifies for
unemployment benefits there are people
who are working under the table as the
phrase maybe there are people in certain
jobs where you don't qualify for
unemployment benefits so the real number
is higher and number two the systems for
filing have been so overwhelmed that
there are tons of people who have been
trying to file but couldn't unemployment
is man administered managed at the state
level like we have the department in
Massud the Massachusetts Department of
Employment that manages Massachusetts
unemployment the websites are often not
up to the the task of handling the
increased traffic the phone systems are
often collapsing so there are lots of
people who have been trying to file but
haven't been able to so in early May the
April unemployment report is going to be
released and it could conceivably hit
fifteen percent unemployment which would
be historically high I mean you have to
go back to the Great Depression era
where you had you know 25 percent in
1933 we've not seen numbers like that 15
maybe even we could get to 20% since
these are tragic numbers it's going to
take a long time to recover regardless
of Trump saying it's gonna go up like a
rocket and we're gonna be reinstating
everything very quickly a lot of jobs
are not going to be reinstated as the
economy starts to open back up many
restaurants and other businesses are not
coming back they are closed for good
it's going to be a long process many
people will be starting essentially from
scratch looking for new jobs now a few
reminders here is Donald Trump's press
I'm sorry Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross
saying just weeks ago that coronavirus
will be good for the economy while
giving us a hacking cough as he says it
take a look I don't want to talk about a
victory lap over a very unfortunate very
malignant disease but the fact is it
does give businesses yet another thing
to consider when they go through their
review of their supply chain on top of
all the other things because that you
had SARS you have the African swine
virus there now you have this
it's another risk factor that people
need to take into account so I think it
will help to accelerate the return of
jobs to North America some to us
probably some to Mexico so we can add
that to the montage of really clueless
people who have no idea what they're
talking about now in the meantime and
we're going to talk about this in the
interview segment today people still
haven't gotten their 1200 dollar
stimulus cheques from reports I'm seeing
the unemployment supplement from the
federal government of up to $600 a week
still hasn't started in many if not
almost all of the states that are
through which people are receiving
unemployment benefits not to a
significant degree
despite Trump's claims during his press
conferences that billions and billions
of dollars in the Paycheck Protection
Plan funds have been doled out already
it seems that very few businesses have
actually received any money so far we're
months into this thing now and where are
those benefits where is the money these
are very
numbers they are made worse by the fact
that the Trump administration has been
so brutally behind on all of this so we
need a government that can actually
behave responsibly and react quickly we
don't have it right now there's a
YouTube channel we're partnering with
that I would love for you to check out
it's a channel called up flip you can
get there by clicking the link below
make sure you subscribe when you're
there every week up flip uploads a new
video where you get an exclusive
behind-the-scenes look at a different
small business everything from real
estate firms coffee shops auto repair
shops each business owner shares a ton
of really interesting insight about how
they built their business what it's like
day-to-day how they got to where they
are fascinating to learn about other
people's business strategies how they
found success it's a great channel for
anyone thinking of starting a business
already running one or just people
interested in how different business
work perfect for people who like TV
shows like shark tank and that type of
thing check it out at david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is underneath the
video they are friends of the David
Pakman show make sure to subscribe when
you're there click that Bell icon to be
notified when they upload new videos